one of the women that you spoke to about
to contribute to the book was theresa
may
um how do you reflect or how did you
both reflect on
how she was treated in her role
one of the contributors was theresa may
that's right in the book to
eight women who either had or are
presidents or prime ministers plus
hillary clinton of course
uh theresa may's experience actually
echoed that of a number of the other
women
she talked about a differential focus on
appearance she talked about
the tight rope that women have to walk
between
strength and empathy she talked to about
disproportionate media attention
in her emotional reactions constant
questioning of her press people about
whether she was going to be moved to
tears whether she was going to cry
and of course when she gave her final
press conference that was largely
reported
as if she had been sobbing whereas if
you watch the footage yourself that's
simply not true
so she did have a number of experiences
in common with other women leaders
she i think as far as the book is
concerned she said
if a male leader cries he's seen as
patriotic
but if a woman cries she's seen as over
emotional that's a pretty narrow
tightrope for women to walk in power
isn't it
it's an extraordinary narrow tightrope
and we know
it exists not just because women like
theresa may
speak of it but because there's been
academic research
into this tightrope there have been
universities that have done
things like got randomised groups of
voters
presented one group with a male
candidate another group with a female
candidate
got them to deliver exactly the same
script
and then monitored the reactions and we
know from that kind of research work
that unless women weave a very narrow
path
between being tough enough to lead but
still looking at
nurturing and caring unless they get
that right
then they can be very much rejected by
voters and particularly a woman
who is seen not to be caring or
empathetic
who seem to be a very tough leader will
get a very visceral
and adverse reaction from voters i have
a friend
who was a man and he is a scientist he
gave
a conference speech and he decided to
transition into being a woman changed
his name
some years later about four years later
gave him a speech
again within the same group and the
feedback for
him then as a woman was your brother was
better than you were
how surprised are you with that doesn't
that say
absolutely everything and we do know
from other studies that this is in fact
a very common experience
there was an american study where a
course was
taught wholly online and people never
actually met
the teacher and so they got a male
teacher
to say he was male to the students a
female teacher to say she was female
but then in different classes they
swapped up the roles
and when students believed that they
were being taught by a male
teacher they gave better evaluations
even though in truth it was exactly the
same person who was teaching them
both in the guys as a man and as a woman
and so
yes unfortunately we do still evaluate
so much through the prism of gender and
the book is an attempt to get us to
think about that
to think about how global it is i'm a
co-author
an african friend of mine dr ngozia
conjury wheeler wrote this book with me
and we're asking people in all cultures
and contexts to think about
how we still don't give women leaders an
equal go
and what we can do to change that
do we expect women leaders to react
differently
to global pandemics like
coronavirus and covet 19.
i don't know if we expect them to but
there is some
evidence coming out now that women
leaders have generally done
better in the grips of the pandemic this
is actually uk
academic research from development
economists and the conclusion that they
come to is that women leaders are
more risk averse than male leaders
perhaps they intuitively know that women
do
still pay a greater price for errors and
as a result
the women leaders of countries tended to
go for
quicker restrictions to control the
spread of the virus
and that has been a good strategy to
save lives and to minimise illness
i do want to talk to you of course about
tony abbott
he's a hot topic here in the united
kingdom at the moment as i'm sure you
know you were one of the first people to
call him out
as a misogynist why do you think he was
and do you think he still is
well i said everything i needed to say
about
that back in october 2012 and that
speech is still doing the rounds all of
these years later
and i stand by every word of it but i
don't think
that i need to add to it so i put my
views on the record
of course it's not for me to work out
who should be the
uk trade envoy or specialist this is a
decision for the uk government
and ultimately for the views of the
people of britain so i will leave all of
that to you
well let's have a quick listen let's
remind our viewers and for those who
haven't heard what you said here's a
quick
snippet of what you said at the time i
will
not be lectured about sexism and
misogyny by this man i will not
and the government will not be elected
about sexism and misogyny
by this man not now not ever
and he also stood in front of placards
that described you as a witch and
another man's
[ __ ] i know that you say that you don't
want to talk about it but do not feel
slightly that you that you have a voice
here and that for women
who potentially find themselves in a
position where they
are undermined by men that somebody of
your experience
to have a word or two about what might
happen would be valuable to them
i certainly do think that i've got a
voice and having had those experiences
that i spoke about in 2012
it's motivated me to go on and to try
and
get the message out about women about
gender equality
that's what brings me regularly to the
united kingdom with king's college
london i established and it's still
thriving a global
institute for women's leadership getting
through fantastic research work
even in the middle of lockdowns and
other disruptions
and it's what's motivated me with ngosi
to write this book
i can't personally mentor or speak to
every woman
who wants to learn from my experiences
but what i can do
is write them down and make them
available and that's what the book's
about
i do wish that i'd had a book like this
when i was starting out because i think
forewarned is forearmed
and if you can think for yourself how
you will deal with those gendered
moments
when unfortunately they inevitably come
then
it will be an easier time to get through
than just
encountering them as i did and trying to
work out what to do in the moment
yeah but you are a strong woman as am i
you know we don't tolerate
misogyny and younger women who were
trying to bring up the greasy pearl with
us are looking to women like us to
support them
when you call out somebody as a
misogynist is it appropriate that he
potentially then
is a trade envoy for a country the other
side
of the world and the health secretary of
that country saying
doesn't matter what he said previously
because he is good at trade
how does that make you feel infuriated
me what about you
[Laughter]
uh well i've been through too many of
these kinds of experiences
to end up being infuriated uh
look this is a decision for the uk and
you know i'm not a citizen of the uk i
was of course born there
but i'm not a citizen of the uk so it's
for your democratic politics to make a
decision
i think my views are clear they're well
known
i don't need to add to them they're no
mystery to people
but you stand by what you said in that
speech some time ago that
tony abbott is a misogynist as far as
you're concerned
i certainly stand by every word of that
speech
i doubt that i'll ever be able to put
it better in my life than the things
that i said
that day on misogyny and so i'll let
that speech speak for
itself okay and your new book is out now
is it
yes it is in the united kingdom now